[Music]
glory to
the new newborn king
peace on earth and mercy
mind god and sinners
[Music]
proclaim is
glory to the new
[Music]
christ there
offspring
[Music]
[Applause]
please
[Music]
jesus
you
[Music]
prince of peace
feeling
[Music]
[Applause]
going to give them second birthday
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
hi everyone good evening and welcome to
the table
we are live this sunday night so glad
you're here my name is karen miner
and i'm part of the leadership team and
whether you are joining us for the first
time
or you've been with us for a while i
hope
you are sitting in a cozy place and
that you feel welcome here that's what
the table is
there is a place for you and i hope that
the service tonight
reminds you that you are loved
you are not alone and no matter what
circumstances surround you
you are loved by god and you are loved
by us
as well so if you could do me a favor
and
take a moment and comment down below let
us know
that you're watching we want to make
sure to connect with you personally so
don't be shy
say hello and uh let our community
welcome you and uh happy
christmas season it's upon us we are
here it's hard to believe that
uh next week is christmas it's
you know with the pandemic time has been
really really weird
in some ways there's been times that
have gone by really slowly
and other times it's just gone by so
quickly i can't believe we're at the end
of the year
but here we are and here's to a better
2021 as far as the pandemic goes
and a lot of other things so i just have
a couple of announcements
tonight speaking of christmas we have
our christmas eve
service coming up next week on the 24th
we are doing our first in what nine
months
outdoor in-person service for christmas
eve
um we're gonna be back at pleasant
valley united methodist church
in saxi and i believe that marissa's
going to post a link
with the address to pleasant valley
because there are a lot of you who have
joined us
in the last nine months that have never
stepped foot at pleasant valley so
we're really happy to be able to get
together now please please please keep
in mind
we want this to be a safe gathering for
everyone
uh who chooses to be there so bring your
mask
prepare to socially distance we're gonna
spread out
bring your own chair bring your own mask
we're going to gather together at 3 30
pm for some music
and worship scripture readings
prayer it's going to be really really
beautiful and you can join us
either in person or we'll also be
right here online uh streaming it live
so i hope you'll be able to join us and
feel free to invite
friends and family anybody else that you
think might
want to be a part of it
also the following sunday which is
sunday december 27th
we will not be having a sunday service
we will not have an online service no
in-person gathering we are taking the
27th off
which feels a little radical for
christians usually gosh we're right back
the next sunday with
uh with our regular services but you
know
at the table we really value rest we
want to give our leaders
volunteers some time off it does take a
lot of work and effort and energy
and time to put these services together
especially a christmas service with so
many moving parts so
uh we are going to take sunday the 27th
off
enjoy that time however you like and
then we'll be back
the following sunday january 3rd with
our usual online services we're not
doing in person it's just a one-off for
christmas eve
um and then we'll be back for our online
services on january 3rd so i hope you'll
join us for that
so as we transition into worship
let's pray together and remember jesus
god thank you for
for jesus for
being god in the flesh for jesus showing
us
in human form the character of you of
god
and we reflect and center on you right
now
and just remember jesus who
came to earth dwelled among us
in all of humanity and also
in just as as god
as well and that that part is a mystery
it's a mystery to me
but it's also such a picture of
of who god is if i'm ever wondering
what god is like i just look to
the character and nature of jesus who
didn't
didn't come in you know pomp and
circumstance and
wealth and power but came in humility
and uh just as an ordinary
baby vulnerable um
and you know the the path was not was
not easy for jesus
and that gives me such comfort right now
because the path isn't easy for us
sometimes
but we can follow just the example and
model of jesus
and persevere and hang in there and
continue to return
to our faith so god for anyone tonight
who is struggling with their faith
for anybody who is questioning you god
i pray that they would sense your
presence tonight
that they would catch a glimpse of your
glory and your orchestration and your
goodness
remind us god that you can be trusted
and that we can look to the story of
jesus from the birth
all the way through to the resurrection
just to know that you are trustworthy
you are good
you are faithful and that we
can have hope in you so god
we center on you tonight we center
on the person and the life of jesus
and we give you our hearts
speak to us tonight and
we trust you god it's in jesus name i
pray
[Music]
amen
oh
[Music]
me
is
[Music]
trees
is
[Music]
foreign
me
[Music]
is
hmm
[Music]
oh my god
there is
[Music]
says
is
[Music]
hey guys it's so good to be with y'all
tonight and i just wanted to read us
this passage out of luke
2. it's when the angels
appeared to the shepherds out in the
field
it says and there were shepherds living
out in the fields nearby watching over
their flocks at night
an angel of the lord appeared to them in
the glory of the lord
shone around them and they were
terrified
but the angel said to them don't be
afraid
i bring you good news of great joy that
will be for all
people today in the town of david a
savior has been born to you
he is christ the lord and this will be
assigned to you
you will find a baby wrapped in class
and lying in a manger
suddenly a great company of the heavenly
host appeared with the angel praising
god
and saying glory to god in the highest
and on earth peace to men
on whom his favor rests
that passage stood out to me this week
with our worship set
um as we were kind of talking about um
or you know dealing with fear in our
lives and
brett's gonna be talking about that
tonight and um
i just wonder if one of god's messages
to us today is the same as the message
that the angels gave
um to the shepherds
and if he would tell us there's a lot
going on
but don't be afraid i have good news
and it's for all people um
and instead of fear i'm giving you peace
god i just pray that you would fill us
with your peace
in this season god and i just thank you
that your love helps us
to conquer all
so
[Music]
is
she no longer
[Music]
is
oh
[Music]
is
you say
[Music]
oh
in the is
[Music]
oh
is
[Music]
foreign
um
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
oh
[Music]
me
jesus thank you for a safe place
[Music]
thank you for jesus who came into our
broken world
and brought light
[Music]
very close this christmas
thank you for your love jesus
[Music]
until that we normally try to pay
attention
here at the table our highest value is
flawlessness
it's awesome well good evening everyone
grace and peace
welcome welcome to the table so glad you
could be with us
and um i'm yeah i'm just glad to be here
with you online not you know here here
but you know what i mean
so this is part um five in our series
titled stretch thin what to do when life
pushes you to the limit
uh it's been you know a stretching year
a difficult year a year of isolation of
pressure
and yet you know also deeply
transformative here if we have the eyes
to see
if we allow our souls to be shaped by
the experience that was
um a lot of what we dug into last week
so if you missed that that message i
encourage you to
go on our podcast and give that a listen
um
but tonight the title of my message uh
is fear not fear not
and our texts we're actually gonna have
two texts from the christmas story luke
chapter one and luke chapter two
and we'll begin let's see with luke one
this is verses 26 through
30 one and it says
this so in the sixth month of
elizabeth's pregnancy
god sent the angel gabriel to nazareth a
town in galilee
to a virgin pledged to be married to a
man named joseph a descendant of david
the virgin's name was mary
the angel went to her and said greetings
you who are
highly favored the lord is with you
mary was greatly troubled at his words
and wondered what kind of greeting this
might be
but the angel said to her do not
be afraid mary
do not be afraid you have found favor
with god you will conceive and give
birth to a son
and you are to call him jesus
and skipping down this is chapter 2
verses 8 through 12.
and there were shepherds living out in
the fields nearby keeping watch over
their flocks at night
an angel of the lord appeared to them
and the glory of the lord shone around
them and they were terrified
but the angel said to them do not
be afraid i bring you good news
that will cause great joy for all the
people
today in the town of david a savior has
been born to you
he is the messiah the lord this will be
a sign to you
you will find a baby wrapped in cloths
and lying
in a manger so here's my big idea for
tonight
fear paralyzes and
stupefies but faith gives us
a calm and a creativity by which
we conquer i think that'll come to make
more sense as
i go throughout the message so um you
know just like mary
and just like the shepherds i think our
great temptation
this christmas really you might say this
year
is one of fear it's it's not something
we necessarily you know wear on our
sleeves
per se it's it's mostly inside us and we
try to keep it kind of buttoned up
but but it's there and you know fear
fears
it's it's a funny thing because it can
kind of descend
upon us in one of two ways it can
roll in slowly like a fog
or it can strike like a thunderbolt
it can roll in like a fog or it can
strike like a thunderbolt let's talk
about
um the fog first so when
fear rolls in like a fog it's
almost imperceptible to us like we don't
even know
what is happening it sort of reminds me
a little bit of another metaphor known
as
um the fog of war perhaps you've heard
this this phrase
it's i think it's from former us
secretary of defense robert mcnamara he
gave this metaphor the fog of war
and he said the fog of war it is total
it's a total um uncertainty
that surrounds you in the moment in the
midst of war
right you're just uncertain about
yourself
your own capabilities the capabilities
of your adversary
their exact intents like you think you
know but it's it's just
all very hazy and
um i think that's you know that's what
the fog of fear is like as well
you just you don't quite know what's
happening
right i mean it's always easy um
you know to monday morning quarterback
it so to speak to like oh you should
have done is this but but when you're in
the moment
um you know all you know is everything's
kind of hazy
unclear your decision-making is sort of
off
uh or at least in retrospect you see
that it was off
but in the moment like you you really
had no idea
that it was an underlying sort of
general anxiety or or
fear a fear of the unknown uh an
uncertainty about the future
that was driving you and and when the
just that fog of fear rolls in
um what's actually most likely is
not that you do something stupid right
that you make a stupid decision
uh it's it's that you don't do anything
at all you ever been there
like you're paralyzed by the haze
like a driver in a fog so thick
you just can't see more than a few feet
in front of you and so you know just
everything feels dangerous and you
simply pull the car
off to the side of the road i remember
one night i was on a drive and it wasn't
the fog but it was rain
it was so thick that i just
i mean even going 20 miles an hour or 10
miles an hour it felt
dangerous like i could not see
and so what could i do nothing i just
pulled off to the side of the road and
just sat
and and i think that's that's sort of a
picture of fear in a way
right it's sort of um it can drive us it
can but but this is you know this fog
metaphor this is it's sort of the subtle
kind of fear
just everything's hazy i'm just really
anxious
i don't know what to do so i think i'm
just gonna do
nothing that's fog as fear
but of course there's there's another
kind of fear
in our lives isn't there this is when
fear strikes like a
thunderbolt we are suddenly what's the
word
we're sort of seized by it um it's what
neuroscientists
call a a limbic hijacking the limbic
brain this is the part of your brain
i'm having to do primarily with emotion
you know with feeling
and so so olimbic hijacking is
it's an emotional takeover
you ever been mentally hijacked by fear
it's unbelievable it's like one minute
you're fine
and then that person says that thing
or you get that news about a family
member or a friend or you have
that conversation with a colleague or a
spouse or your child
and you know whatever it is but while 60
seconds before
you were perfectly at ease
suddenly you're hijacked
it's just you're taking over and it's
fear fear has
struck like a thunderbolt
and you are so not
okay and it's it's strange
because this is precisely not the time
to be making rash decisions
uh and yet if you're at all like me when
the thunderbolt of fear
strikes uh you're all like you know
a solution that's how i get a solution a
solution like i need a solution
a plan i need a plan i need a three-step
plan immediately
to get me out of this because if i have
a plan
then i feel in control again and i
desperately need control again
because i feel very vulnerable right now
and i freaking hate feeling vulnerable
and out of control
i hate it with all my might and so i'm
going to make decisions right now
to alleviate this fear and anxiety here
i go here i go
watch me i'm reacting this is gonna be
awesome
this is the genius solution i'm gonna
i'm sending the text i'm doing it i'm
calling the lawyer
i'm dealing with this situation now
because
fear has struck me like a thunderbolt
and i feel stupid
or inadequate or rejected or alone
so here i go i'm firing off the text i'm
making the call
oh my gosh this is um that's what i mean
by the way by the word stupefy and
that's a weird word
that's that's called um being stupefied
like literally it it sort of um
renders me stupid but
but what's underneath all those feelings
and reactions fear
fear i'm i'm afraid i'm afraid and i
just want it to stop
i just i just want it to go away
and of course the great irony is that
you know normally whatever
genius decisions i make when i'm in the
grip of fear are of course profoundly
foolish
um when i'm struck by the thunderbolt of
fear that like that's precisely
not the time to be taking drastic action
that's when i need to pull the car over
so to speak and sit on the side of the
road
uh and regain my sanity um but that's
precisely when i step on the gas
and barrel four because i just want to
get out of here
i heard recently a line i love this line
uh
i wish i could remember the source of it
but they said you know what humanity
needs
are cool heads and warm hearts
not good cool heads
warm hearts that that's what i need
i need a cool head and a warm heart
but when i'm struck by the thunderbolt
of fear
it's the exact opposite
i have a cold heart ice is
in my heart and my head
is on fire my my thoughts are racing
a thousand miles per hour there i have
cold heart um not just warm head hot
head my it's i mean lord have mercy
this is it's a crazy place to be uh and
of course
you know the trick is that in both the
examples um i gave
above this these metaphors of the fog
and the thunderbolt
um the challenge is that it's it's just
highly unlikely that we will
be aware of the fact much less
admit to ourselves and those around us
that we are afraid right so so this kind
of asks the question how do you know
like how do i know if fear has rolled in
like a fog or struck me like a
thunderbolt oh goodness boy we could
talk uh about lots of things i found the
the rabbi and writer edwin friedman um
to be
a very helpful voice in all of this he
names a number of different signs so we
could
we could talk about emotional reactivity
when you find yourself in that really
worked up place
um you're reactive it's almost always a
sign of fear
um when we blame right blaming people or
forces for all of our problems instead
of taking
responsibility for our lives it's often
a sign that we're operating in fear
um when we begin to turn
basically turning to our tribe to tell
us what to
think this is sort of the herd mentality
like what do we believe again tell me
what are we going to do
that that's often a sign of fear but the
most interesting one that freed when uh
friedman
talks about um i think it's so
insightful he he calls it um it's
basically the quick
fix mentality here's a definition he
gives a quick fix mentality
is a low threshold for pain that
constantly seeks
symptom relief rather than
fundamental change that's so good
a quick fix mentality this is how you
know when you're operating in
in fear maybe the fog has rolled in
when you you have this low threshold for
pain that
that constantly seeks symptom relief
rather than fundamental change so you'll
recall in my description above
the times i've been under the spell of
of the thunderbolt where i say like we
need to fix this we need to fix this now
i need to feel better i need to feel
better now
uh i mean this is what we do right
individuals do this um
marriages and families kind of do this
churches do this businesses do this
we are afraid we are kind of chronically
anxious
and so we start jumping from quick fix
to quick fix uh and you know at the
individual level
it could be all sorts of vices like
alcohol or
pornography whatever that help kind of
alleviate and avoid
our fear and anxiety or at the
institutional level
um you know it could be organizing
another meeting
so that we feel we've done something or
quickly implementing another program
that we'll then let go of in like two
weeks or a month only to try
another program after that
uh right um like this is it's
um basically just anything quick or easy
we're just jumping around
we're seeking this symptom um relief
it's a sign that we're operating
in fear uh can you see
through through this i mean i'm hoping
certain examples and things are coming
to your mind
not just of others like which is what's
easy to do right like oh my gosh those
people are so afraid
but you know i'm hoping that some
examples are coming to your mind
for you um when you've been a hot mess
because um i really think this is a
huge problem in our world
you might say that in many ways fear is
running the world fear
is running our lives and um
frankly bad people know this and they
take advantage of it
right advertisers know this they take
advantage of it
right um often you know leaders can prey
on this
right fear kind of has us emotionally
flopping around
like fish without enough water uh
it's a it's a huge huge problem and
while it can sound sort of cliche
i think we need to understand to to see
again
uh the radical nature the profound
depth of a word uh that for many of us
has sort of lost its power
uh it's a word that when we hear it i
don't quite know how it'll how it hits
you um i mean your eyes might glaze over
a bit but
honestly that's the case i think that's
because you you really don't
get it like you think you get it but you
don't get it um we don't see
quite how powerful and wonderful it is
we don't understand how it reorients
us in the world and that word of course
is faith where we misunderstand faith is
i think
that we think it's the same as belief
you know i believe in god so i have
faith in god i believe xyz about
god or jesus or the bible so therefore
i'm a person of faith
[Music]
sort of uh i do think belief can play a
part
um but honestly faith it's it's a much
more
fundamental and profound thing than that
um
here's a definition of faith that i
really like
it's faith equals basic trust
faith is this basic trust notice i
didn't just say
trust i said basic trust basic trust is
the sense
that god is on my side
and has provided me inner resources
to just to thrive regardless of my
circumstances say that again basic trust
it's the sense that god is on my side
that he has provided me inner resources
to
thrive regardless of my circumstances
regardless of whatever i'm facing
i'm going to make it not just survive
but i'm going to thrive
in and through this like that's faith i
received
a lot of clarity on this by the way from
a writer
named a h amass uh and he
talks about how some folks you know
might say like well i'm sort of iffy on
god you know i don't really know if i
believe in god the whole
old man the sky thing um but of course
that's like mostly neither here nor
there
because you know instead of the word god
people say things like
i trust the universe is on my side
or i just trust that you know reality
is good um you know which as a christian
like i hear that and i'm like okay so
you pretty much
capitalize those letters or those words
reality
you know the universe you're talking
about god
um and they're like well okay sure
if you want to call it that and i'm like
well i do i do i want to call it that
and so so as a christian in light of how
god has
been revealed in jesus i honestly feel
just that much more confident
um that much more able to be at peace
at rest able to have um that
basic trust that faith just because
you know jesus has revealed god to be so
good uh so full of loving kindness and
compassion like
so on our side that he would
come to earth i mean this is christmas
right that you would come
among us um i mean just
enter into the depths of our life in our
world
right and i think um god is for us and
so you can see how
how this basic trust this
faith is it's the opposite
of what of fear because you know
fear is ego driven fear is fighting for
my place in the world i'm afraid
that there's not enough frankly that i'm
not enough
that i'll not be provided for but faith
oh my gosh faith is the opposite faith
brings
calm faith knows that
all will be well this is why i said at
the beginning
fear paralyzes and stupefies
it literally renders a stupid but faith
what does it do
faith gives us a calm and a creativity
by which we conquer now uh you say what
do you mean by
creativity well remember the quick fixes
quick fixes are inevitably
uncreative they they are low risk
low reward but with faith
with this sort of deep trust suddenly
you know a calm sort of descends over me
and creativity and energy flow
and i'm able by the grace of god in the
holy spirit
to conquer perhaps there's a better word
than conquer
sort of warlike but i needed a word with
a cut sound for poetic symmetry
and i'm uh i'm not that good at coming
up with these little phrases so
conquer it is fear paralyzes and
stupefies
but faith gives us a calm a creativity
by which we conquer i'll close with this
passage
and i think you know mary mary mother of
jesus she's such a beautiful picture of
this faith
um so let's pick up the story it's
towards the end of her conversation
with the angel verse 34 how will this
be mary asked the angel
since i am a virgin the angels
answered the holy spirit will come on
you and the power of the most high will
overshadow you
so the holy one to be born will be
called the son of god
even elizabeth your relative is going to
have a
child in her old age and she who was
said to be unable to conceive and
is in her sixth month for no word from
god will ever
fail verse 38 i am the lord's
servant mary answered may your word
to me be fulfilled
then the angel left her
uh those are not words of fear
she may have begun the conversation if
you'll recall earlier
disturbed mary was disturbed at these
words disturbed and afraid she may have
begun there
but she finished in this posture
of basic trust of
faith and i get that sense you know
especially from that closing line
may your word to me be fulfilled
i mean she didn't have to say that she
could have simply said like well i'm the
lord's servant so
you know me to me as you've said like
okay i guess whatever you say goes
you're the angel um but she doesn't
close with that she
she's names okay i'm the lord servant
may be done unto me as you said but then
she invites it
she welcomes it she moves towards her
destiny with these this wonderful line
may your word to me be fulfilled in
other words
like may it happen bring it on she she
had
moved beyond fear to
faith and i guess that kind of leaves us
with this question
which is what posture will we be in
you know in this season will we be
paralyzed by fear will we be stupefied
by fear
or will we learn to trust god
to operate in wisdom
yeah to trust that he's on our side um
you know the choice is ours
but i wonder what could god do with a
community of people who were
leaning away from fear and into this
basic
trust on this faith i think that could
be a powerful powerful thing for for us
as individuals for our families
our church our broader community so
um let me pray for you that we could all
step into this grow into this lord jesus
i pray that you would
um give us faith not in some kind of
hokey religious sense
um not just in the sense of like
believing some things intellectually
but that you would do a deep deep work
in us god that we would say yes
to the the process that you have us in
where you are trying to
teach us again to trust
and i i just lift up every person
hearing my voice who
really struggles with this they
they just don't trust
god and i admit a lot of times i'm right
there with them
what would you teach us to trust again
teach us to be vulnerable again to know
that you're for us and that we're gonna
be okay
we're gonna be okay we're gonna make it
thank you god for your faithfulness in
the name of jesus i pray
amen
[Music]
i'm no longer
to fear
[Music]
again
oh
[Music]
wow
is
[Music]
oh
is
[Music]
so is
in me
thank you so much for joining us tonight
and i also want to say a big thank you
to josh rollins and marissa martinez
who work behind the scenes tonight on
the service
and also to mindy
and our worship musicians who shivered
out in the cold
to bring us that beautiful worship set
and of course to brett for a great
message
just a good reminder of um you know when
the circumstances and things are
swirling around us
we always have the choice to center on
jesus
and uh you know as you go into the week
um there are christmas lights everywhere
right now
so as you see a light
as small or as big as it might be let
that be a reminder to you
to you personally that god is with you
and god loves you if there's anything we
can do for you as a church community
whether that be prayer
or tangible needs or just a listening
ear
we would love to be there for you the
best way for you to reach out to us
is through our website at thetabletx.org
that's thetabletx.org
send us a message through the website
and we'll get in touch with you
and also if you resonate with our vision
and our values and what we have going on
here including our really really
professional slick
services please consider giving
us a financial gift online you can also
do that through our website
www.thetabletx.org
what that does is it helps our community
to continue to flourish and do the work
we feel that god has called us to do in
any amount
any amount is so appreciated appreciated
and valued um just as your presence is
so thank you thank you again for being
with us tonight
and as you go into the week ahead i want
to send you out with this
benediction and just like seeing the
lights and remembering that god is with
you
i want you to hear this for yourself
please receive this
for you as being god's words to you
personally wherever you are tonight
you are a child of god this is true
on your best days and it's true on your
worst days
you are wonderfully and lovingly made
there is only one you nothing about you
is a mistake and this world needs you
being fully yourself authentic
and free so as you go into the week
ahead with its yet
to be determined highs and lows and
everything in between
go with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy and you are accepted
just as you are and go filled with god's
holy spirit
and the desire to extend these same
gifts of grace
and unconditional love to everyone you
come in contact with
have a great week and we hope to see you
either online or in person
on christmas eve good night
hello
you